[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous alors bonjour on est là
pour parler de changement et en bon
passionné d'économie quand on parle
changement moi j'entends décision il
faut savoir que l'économie s'est
toujours intéressé aux décisions déjà à
cause des énormes conséquences de ces
dernières mais aussi il faut savoir que
traditionnellement on partait du
principe au début de la matière que les
décisions étaient tout rationnel c'est à
dire qu'on était tous des décideurs
logique avec les bonnes informations qui
prenait toujours le meilleur choix se
penser un petit peu à vos dernières
décisions dans votre vie pensez à ce que
vous avez lu au journal ce matin je
pense que l'hypothèse est peut-être un
petit peu optimiste c'est herbert
saimone prix nobel d'économie qui va
être le premier à remettre en cause
cette vision du monde toujours citer un
prix nobel en début de conférence ça
permet d'être crédible derrière herbert
simone parle de l'hypothèse du décideur
rationalité limitée
d'après lui le décideur voit sa
rationalité limitée par les informations
qu'il a à sa disposition et ses
capacités cognitives
c'est donc le bon niveau d'information
et vos capacités intellectuelles qui
feront la différence entre une décision
rationnelle et une décision stupide pour
illustrer ce lien entre information et
décision va commencer par un premier
exemple un excellent exemple d'un grand
changement que nous avons tous connu la
prise de conscience écologique
si aujourd'hui je vous dis que
l'écosystème est en danger et qu'il nous
faudrait trois planètes pour répondre
aux besoins de l'humanité si tout le
monde consommait comme des français vous
serez peut-être apeurés mais pas surpris
l'information a été largement diffusée
il ya même quelqu'un qui a eu un prix
nobel de la paix pour un powerpoint sur
le sujet il faut savoir que cette
information largement diffusé à une
influence sur nos décisions
une récente étude ipsos montre que plus
de la moitié des français sont prêts à
consommer des fruits et légumes de
saison des fruits et légumes qui serait
visuellement abîmé et que plus de 40%
des français disent consommer plus de
produits qui respectent l'environnement
depuis deux ans alors pas seulement mais
plus il ya déjà un mieux
d'un point de vue plus global si on
regarde la production de papier en 1981
33% du papier produit et devenait du
recyclage en 2015 66%
ces informations ont permis aux
personnes d'avoir des gestes écologiques
au quotidien mais aussi ont permis aux
structures de mettre en place les
infrastructures nécessaires au recyclage
donc la bonne information amène à la
bonne décision
alors nous on sent un peu c'est pas
automatique l'information n'est pas le
seul critère est des fois même bien
informée nous prenons des décisions qui
sont horribles et de plus la planète
n'est pas encore sauvé mais on voit
qu'au global une bonne information amène
de meilleures décisions
alors qu'est ce qui se passe lorsqu'on
n'a pas les informations pour ça on va
prendre un deuxième exemple l'exemple
d'un autre grand changement de notre
période
l'explosion des technologies de
l'information et la communication
ces technologies ont changé notre façon
de communiquer de s'informer de travail
et de faire des rencontres même pour
certains et on pense assez naturellement
que ces technologies immatériel ou un
bon impact écologique
mais il n'en est rien car toutes nos
actions virtuelles ont des conséquences
sur les infrastructures réel par exemple
quand on va sur un site internet
le site n'est pas linéaire mais dans un
datacenter
alors un data center c'est un
gigantesque hangar où il ya des tonnes
de machines appelées serveurs qui vont
stocker les sites les photos les vidéos
vos statuts sur les réseaux sociaux
tous les documents que vous avez sur le
cloud aussi alors d'ailleurs on
remarquera que le nom cloud est
peut-être un peu trompeur si je vous dis
cloud nuage ou pour c'est quelque chose
dans l'air de légers qui n'a pas de
conséquences alors qu'en fait le cloud
c'est juste que vos documents lieu
d'être stockée sur votre ordinateur sont
stockés dans un datacenter
quelques chiffres pour situer et je vous
préviens alors les études peuvent donner
des chiffres quelque peu différent mais
on est toujours dans le même ordre
d'idée c'est valable pour tous les
chiffres que je vais donner par la suite
un datacenter en moyenne c'est la
consommation d'une ville de 30 mille
habitants le 1er arrondissement de lyon
les grands datacenters atteignent la
consommation d'une ville de cent mille
habitants
c'est versailles et 40% de cette énergie
c'est même pas pour stocker ces pour
refroidir les machines qui surchauffe en
travaillant la clim la plus chère de
l'histoire on compte plus de 130
datacenter en france mais le datacenter
ce n'est pas tout puisque quand j'ai mon
ordinateur
ma tablette ou smartphone et que je veux
consulter un site qui héberge et sur un
datacenter aux états unis comment
l'information voyage entre les deux à
votre avis l'information entre les
etats-unis et la france c'est ce fait en
wifi en satellite par câble ou en 4g
j'entends des bonnes réponses la réponse
que j'entends plus souvent c'est le
satellite mais en fait ce sont des bons
vieux câbles plus de 360 câble
sous-marin qui représente plus d'un
million de kilomètres de fibre optique
plus que l'aller-retour terre-lune vous
imaginez les ressources et les moyens
pour installer et réparer ces câbles un
câble de fibre optique qui tombe en
panne en plein milieu de l'atlantique
c'est plus compliqué que réparer votre
freebox
une fois qu'on a additionné ces câbles
ses serveurs on arrive à un bilan
énergétique énorme
d'après greenpeace si internet était un
pays ce serait le cinquième consommateur
mondial d'électricité
alors bon ces chiffres nous permettent
de réaliser qu'il ya un problème et
permettent pas forcément de visualiser
les conséquences des actions concrètes
sur internet
donc on va rentrer dans le détail une
recherche google alors une recherche
google
c'est à peu près l'énergie d'une ampoule
12 watts allumée pendant deux heures
mais on sait pas c'est invisible donc
dès qu'on a un débat à la con à être les
amis sur le nom des enfants de johnny
depp ou le taux de consommation de kebab
en charente-maritime recherche google on
le fait tous et comme on le fait tous en
cumulé 140 millions de recherches google
toutes les heures avec le bilan carbone
de milles aller retour paris new york
on peut parler des vidéos aussi visionné
une vidéo sur votre smartphone pendant
pendant une heure toutes les semaines
consommera la fin de l'année autant que
faire tourner deux frigos 9 h 24 pendant
l'année mais on sait pas c'est invisible
donc on regarde des vidéos on s'en fait
passer on va même jusqu'à utiliser
youtube pour écouter de la musique ou de
télécharger la musique puisque c'est
quand même plus pratique et ont cumulé
quang nam style la vidéo dans le même
style à elle toute seule avec ses trois
milliards de vues à utiliser l'énergie
annuelle d'une petite centrale
laisse une seconde pour essayer
d'imaginer la consommation des vidéos de
chats dans le monde
autre chose que nous faisons toujours
avec internet les mails un mail ces
quatre grammes de co2 c'est invisible
ça se voit pas on se rend pas compte
donc on envoie des mails toute la
journée quand c'est aux boulons mais la
terre entière en copie parce que tout le
monde doit être au courant résultat des
courses en cumulé 12 milliards de mails
toutes les heures dans le monde et je le
regarde à chaque fois parce que le
chiffre m'étonne encore ça fait dix-huit
centrale pour nos mails et puis la
facture
que pas de s'alléger puisque tant qu'on
l'a pas supprimé le mail il est où dans
le datacenter
donc oui le mail de brigitte de
l'acompte a envoyé le 3 mars 2006 pour
dire est ce qu'on mange ensemble à midi
tous les jours y consomme de
l'électricité
tant qu'on l'a pas supprimé mais nous en
plus on s'en fiche de ce mail on
pourrait le supprimer mais si on ne sait
pas que ça consomme de l'électricité
pourquoi on le ferait autre grand débat
sur les mails la consommation enfin
l'impression est ce qu'on imprime ou pas
un mail je vous ai ramené une petite
étude de l'ademe qui fait la comparaison
entre impressions et visualisation sur
l'écran pour un mail avec une pièce
jointe d'un méga octet on peut voir à
partir de 3 min 23 minutes 24 de
visionnage il vaut mieux l'imprimer en
noir et blanc recto verso et si vous
poussez votre visionnage jusqu'à 12
minutes 12
vous pouvez l'imprimer en couleurs et en
recto alors pourquoi une fois qu'on sait
ça pourquoi on a tous vu peut-être même
mis en bas de nos mails ce truc-là
adopté l'éco-attitude n'imprimez semaine
que si c'est vraiment nécessaire
et là on a l'exemple on a l'exemple
d'une décision qui est basé sur un
raisonnement logique je vis sur la
planète ce qui sauve la planète je me
sauve en chemin qui part d'une bonne
intention mais qu'il est complètement
contre productif parce qu'on n'a pas la
bonne information au départ alors je
vous dis tout ça sur internet
vous remarquerez l'ironie de la
situation je vous ai fait un powerpoint
avec des informations trouvées sur
internet ils pouvaient être diffusée sur
youtube derrière donc aujourd'hui je
sais pas si on peut se passer d'internet
par contre on est peut-être dans une
situation où on peut essayer de
connaître les conséquences de nos
actions pour pouvoir calculer le coût
bénéfice de ce qu'on fait est de savoir
si ça vaut le coup est-ce que poster la
vidéo de montchal si important
aujourd'hui
en tout cas l'exemple d'internet n'en
est qu'un parmi tant d'autres j'aurais
pu prendre l'amiante
quand on ne savait pas que c'est mauvais
pour la santé on en a mis partout pour
protéger les personnes des incendies
mauvaise information mauvaise décision
on a appris les conséquences on l'a
retiré bonne information bonne décision
et on pourrait faire ça pendant des
heures certains me diront aussi que le
l'action individuelle ne sert à rien si
elle n'est pas suivie par les actions
des structures puisque après tous ces
data center sont hébergés enfin seront
fabriqués par des entreprises n'est pas
des ehpad et des particuliers et ces
personnes auront raison cependant les
structures comme les individus ont
besoin de la bonne information pour
prendre les bonnes décisions et je vous
assure aussi qu'une sur une structure a
beaucoup plus de mal à prendre une
décision irresponsable si elle a en face
des citoyens et des consommateurs
informés et avertit alors si je n'ai
qu'un seul message dans cette conférence
c'est soyez curieux
renseignez vous apprenez débattent et
discuter crier au monde entier ce qui
d'après vous mérite d'être reçus parce
qu'il n'ya jamais il n'y a pas plus
responsable plus rationnelle et plus
investi qu'un acteur informer qui
connaît les conséquences de ses actes
merci
[Applaudissements]